today we're gonna be reacting to the
video I saw recently so uh let's check
it out hello everyone this is Matthew
Hussey from love life we have another
caller on the line today your name is
Kalani am i right in saying that correct
yeah I am really puzzled by a modern day
commitment
it seems that like people have a really
hard time committing news days like
there's always something better out
there and I'm sure social media has a
lot to do with it people comparing their
lives to others and I know in LA where I
live there's a lot of men have Peter Pan
syndrome and they don't want to grow up
Peter Pan syndrome do Michael Jackson he
so when it's sexual liberation for women
and they get to take their time choosing
that's freedom freedom from oppression
but when men want to stay picky and stay
choosing then they're just not growing
up but it makes me worry to get into
relationship because I feel like you
know people are always kind of worried
about maybe there's something better out
there and there's something better than
you okay people are passing on you
here's the thing we live in an age of
hyper again people pass on you you
trying to find comfort here you not will
find it no listen we all have to be you
know honest about where we are in the
dating totem pole okay some of us are in
the middle some of us are at the bottom
so for us at the top all right a lot of
women is just living delusions a lot of
women think they up here when they're
like here you know don't see no girls
that have a hard time keeping guys awake
yeah
like the guys all want them Yeah right I
know girls like that yeah I know guys
like that yeah why cuz they're more
desired they're not saying like Oh women
are passing on me because there's
something more desirable no they're like
I have to fight these hoes off I'm not a
yes-man if you come to me I'm gonna be
telling you the real King my real
tingling I'm not a yes-man so I had one
of my friend one of my girlfriend came
to me she's like yeah I don't find
anybody there's no man and I'm like yeah
okay what do you have to offer
I want this I want that you wanna ten
but you were six you want him to buy you
[ __ ] that you can't even afford you want
to be catered to but you don't cook he
brings all of that what are you gonna
bring that's right we live in the age of
hypercam what does that mean that means
that a select fewer at the top and that
everybody wants to day with them and
they have their selection of the pool
that is the way we take life right why
because we opened the world up thanks to
feminism thanks to advancements we've
made it so that anybody can date whoever
they choose and you know what now that
we have equal opportunity men know that
they don't have to stay and live with
you and marry you to have sex with you
men are getting a lot of what they want
without having to give up what they
don't want to give up which is their
time they don't want to give up their
space they don't want to give up their
emotions to you because they don't feel
like you're worthy of that most men and
most people under 30 want to be in a
relationship that is a fact most people
aspire to something better for their
relationship life they just don't want
to choose wrong so they don't pick and
they're not picking you because you're
the wrong choice listen I know where I
stand
how about that I'm at that cusp of being
attractive right I mean that seven-run
you did before
I'm the before the B you know I mean hey
you know say what makes it makes it did
you just use the before here's how I
know here's how I know I can get laid
with attractive women but I've never had
women come up to me and be like I want
your number I want this I want that
I've almost 99% of the time have to done
the approaching and it gets me places
and I know well you know it gets me in
places you know say okay in places but I
have friends Wentworth okay what places
warm places places that I got to get wet
and irrigate you know I'm saying sugar
wall places hey Jose
hey I redid some pelvic floors you know
say hey let's go so so that's a
difference let me redo your basement for
you hey hey I'm in shock I didn't say
it's construction Bob we'll do some
drilling
okay all right I got my hard hat on my
knee pads and my timberlands good see
fluffy like it's a black porno girl
let's go [ __ ] kneepads so the
difference between my friends like our
friends were very attractive and they
tell me like yeah girls come up to me
all the time and that's a the difference
between on the cusp of being attractive
and being attractive you know I mean I
think people are fed this narrative that
they are entitled to love they are
entitled to the perfect mess they're
entitled to find someone who's going to
quote-unquote complete them and the
truth is you're not and the day and age
where you get to choose and you get to
be as free as you want that comes with
consequences it means that we get to be
selective as well and if you're not
going to give us a sec somebody else I
mean firstly I think in general people
are worse at committing to anything
these days I think people are worse at
committing to careers I think their
words are committing to a life path I
think they're worse at committing to
marriage I think we we have shorter
attention spans and also we have it I
think a certain level of entitlement
these days that makes us feel like we're
entitled to a job that is amazing and
exciting the whole time and as soon as
it's not we feel like we need to quit
and move on to something else
I think we feel like we're entitled to a
relationship there isn't any work that's
supposed to be easy and then as soon as
it's not we start looking for the next
thing and not to mention if you live in
a place like LA and people in London or
New York or many major cities will all
relate to this you do face a lot of
people with a lot of different options
and everything is it's in a city like
this it's everything all the time
it's everything always you can have
whatever you want any time of day you
can go out every night of the week there
are always new people there's an endless
stream of them there's always something
else going on and that makes it somewhat
difficult now what we have to understand
is that there are different experiences
of life there's the experience for
example of going out and sleeping with
multiple people and having a kind of
roster of people on the go that you
enjoy and you're just seeing where that
takes you and you have all the variety
that comes with that then you have the
experience which is being with one
person
and sharing your day with them and
figure it finding out how they are when
they get home and telling them how you
are when you get home and you know you
go and you go and do something with that
person and you can really relate to them
but that's a long segue to see that
you're not the top choice but he doesn't
want to tell it to her no because I
invite viewers or women I guarantee you
if I looked at his viewership rate it's
probably 90% women who listen to his
stuff and they like his advice but he
also packages his advice in a way that's
palatable for women but we don't give a
[ __ ] about our viewership will tell you
[ __ ] like straight it's probably
because you trash that you can't find
something it's not that we don't give a
[ __ ] about you is that we don't give a
[ __ ] so much about feelings the feeling
gets in the way of the truth sometimes
yeah but you know they again you feel it
and you see the truth and you able to
move on people grow and as they mature
hopefully mature not every guy does but
as they mature they start to have they
value experiences differently some
people go through their lives and they
begin to truly value that sense of real
meaning and connection that comes with
being with one person other people by
the way never get to that stage I
actually I truly believe that that's the
minority I think the most people
actually get to a point where they want
more meaning in their lives yes that's
very good to hear man is not selling
dating-wise he's selling hope yes and
this [ __ ] is buying he basically told
her later on men are gonna want a wife
you because they're gonna exhaust all
their options and you're gonna be left
that's what you said you're not you're
not plan a you're not playing B you're
not C be great you plant see you later
like in a couple years disease because
that's kind of what I was wondering is
you know how things have changed you
know and I think of my parents and the
sixties whatever it was such a natural
thing to commit to somebody and that's
what you did and now it's stopped
mentioning the 60s stop mentioning baby
boomers stop mention that era it was not
a better than your grandparents married
whoever the [ __ ] was around them that's
it
I'm so sick of people bringing up the
old ages like it was better the baby
boomers had the most high divorce rates
ever so they didn't know [ __ ] about
commitment all the new [ __ ] about was
commitment to destroying families they
can go [ __ ] themselves bro you know
you've all I can
class right and and the girls are really
ugly right and if you're a girl and you
like guys different if you like
non-binary minor whatever whatever
you're in that class and the girl the
girl the girls are not looking good so
the most good-looking girl starts to
look hot yeah yes your standard start to
low or [ __ ] I used to live in Ottawa
tenders are low okay
Ottawa you walked in the streets and you
treat a hot woman like his Discovery
Channel hey hey I'm fine no Jennifer
Lopez and this looks like George George
Lopez from Jamie Jo did and now it seems
more unnatural to do that because you
know divorce is cover and things but
another life divorce is no longer
present we've got divorced two all-time
lows okay why because people are not
getting married young marriages I start
before the age of 30 have a think eighty
percent failure rate okay so people are
realizing that it's a giant financial
risk that most people fail so they're
marrying later on in life and it's also
very positive because nowadays people
marry for reasons other than finances
and they actually married a person that
they choose and not the person that's
around remember what I said about the
classroom you realize that oh [ __ ]
there's not a classroom there's a whole
[ __ ] school there's other schools and
then other schools and then you find out
with the internet you connected to every
school Oh see
so that's enough so then your standards
change many guys because of this sense
of entitlement where we think God I
before I get to a certain age I have to
have played around enough I have to have
traveled enough I've had to have had a
ton of adventure I need to have made a
certain amount of money I need to be as
in a certain place in my status in my
career they have all of these things
that they feel like they need to check
off before they meet the woman that
they're gonna spend their life with and
settle down here's the problem
despite this sense of entitlement many
of them never achieve all of those
things by the time they meet that woman
so all of a sudden they're meeting this
amazing woman and they think god I could
marry this woman I could spend my life
with this woman
only I'd been to all those countries I
already wanted to go to if only I feel
like I played around enough had enough
adventure if only I'd already made that
money that I said I'd make it I said I'd
be a millionaire by thirty I'm not I
need to keep going with that they have
all of these things that they feel like
they haven't done yet when they meet
that person and all of a sudden they
find themselves sabotaging a
relationship not because the
relationships wrong but because they
feel like they haven't arrived at that
place in their life just yet that's so
profound and talk to women like I'm not
ready for marriage right now I'm still
discovering myself I'm going through
experiences you know I have so many
things I want to do before I get to that
place hmm and when men do the same thing
they're being immature
yes right they're not they're not there
yet right of course we need a sense of
adventure we need to face adversity to
understand who we are as human being so
that's what that period between the ages
18 to 30 are all about you know I've
changed so much over the last two three
years I can only imagine over the last
ten years how much me as a human being
has changed to marry somebody and to
tell them I'm gonna be with you who is
you over the next 20 years who is you
gonna be the next 30 years are you still
gonna love the person I am ten years
from now so isn't it possible that men
much like women are just discovering
themselves or finding out things they
like and they don't like through
experimentation to experience and
through adventure isn't that a
possibility rather than just saying men
are immature this is what makes him a
little disingenuous in my opinion is
that he has a lot of critiques about how
men behaved and and you know he does a
lot of things from the female
perspective and I just to me seems very
disingenuous that is so profound and
she's sitting there like this is so
profound you know why it's profound
because it doesn't make her happy to
reflect about her own behavior so she
loves this advice it makes everyone else
wrong and her find the easiest thing you
can do for yourself is to look for guys
in the right stage of their lives in
Troy instead of trying to convert guys
in the wrong stage of their lives
if you want to find a guy in the right
stage of his life or you want to find
out if a guy is in the right stage of
his life simply ask him the right
questions when you're early on ask him
you know what sort are you interested in
a relationship at this stage in your
life or do you feel like you still
more that you want to get out of your
system if you talk about his past
relationship why did you break up with
that person that will tell you a lot by
the way does he talk about it being you
know he's the reason that they broke up
because he wasn't ready for a
relationship or is it because of
something that she was doing and
therefore he just hadn't found the right
person if you ask the questions he'll
give you the answers most women never
ask the questions and so they never get
the truth from a guy because they don't
want to hear it there's these questions
is look at how he behaved that's it do
they respond to your messages do they
make efforts to see you patterns alright
give you if men are giving you their
time they're interested and if they're
giving you their time consistently and
they'll give you their attention they're
interested because most of time we don't
want to give you our time or we don't
want to give your attention but we do so
because we know that's what you want we
go for okay so if men is giving you that
stuff great news as far as the questions
we don't even necessarily lie I may
really want to be in a relationship
doesn't mean I'm gonna be want to be in
a relationship with you
and I was like I've been saying since
the beginning of this video Kalani you
ain't [ __ ] because you ain't [ __ ] I
therefore want to be relationship just
not with you if you have to look outward
lead in order to find the reasons why
you suck at dating then the problem is
you alright so that's it for today's
video leave your questions below if you
guys have a dating question you want to
answer or if you have a video we want us
to react to you know send us a send us
an email or drop us a comment below we
want to hear from you yes please
[Music]